joining me now is Saul weisenberg former
deputy independent counsel Saul um where
do you stand here given what seems to be
a building real dossier of information
showing Joe Biden's ties to Hunter and
his business dealings is this the best
time now to proceed with impeachment
proceedings against Joe Biden
Laura I agree with you and I don't think
we're quite there yet I do think there
would be
the danger real danger of a backlash and
there would be sympathy for President
Biden but but we're getting closer with
every new
revelation that comes out and the the
Devon Archer looks like it's it's the
latest and you have a number of things
you've got uh I want to make one point
really clear the president and his
Defenders keep saying he never
interfered in the hunter Biden
investigation
every time he says I'm confident my son
has done nothing wrong and he'll be
cleared he interferes when he came in
and gave a social call to the Delaware
U.S attorney's office when his son was
being investigated that's interference
when his two hand-picked political U.S
attorneys won in Washington DC and one
in Los Angeles turned down David Weiss
and said we're not going to let you
prosecute Hunter Biden in our district
that's political interference so as
these things build up we we're getting
closer to that point but I agree with
you there's a real danger of moving too
quickly investigate all you want don't
necessarily call it an impeachment yet
speaker McCarthy was discussing his call
for this potential impeachment inquiry
earlier today watch this you have the
president saying one thing that we prove
it is not true you've got IRS
whistleblower saying something when it
comes to government treating the bidens
different you've got an informant
claiming that the Biden family had been
bribed
should you ignore that or you should
investigate that the only way you can
investigate that is through an
impeachment inquiry
Saul is that is that the case I mean to
get to the facts that are needed in this
case even deeper maybe more closely bank
records tied to Joe Biden himself or
other family members do you need that
inquiry to go forward
well you obviously do not because
Congressman Comer has been incredibly
successful in finding the bank records
and show all the laundered money that
went to the the Biden related llc's so
you you can do a lot but I do think it's
very important and significant that the
president has said for two years he
never discussed business with his son an
obvious fault said that they're now you
know they're now pulling back on and you
know on this question of co-location
that's a great area this this question
of the the the WhatsApp call where he
says Hunter says I've got my dad's
sitting right here with me this is a
great example of the intersection of
impeached possible impeachment and and
and the interference because the agents
remember the whistleblowers said can we
just do co-location and find out we can
find out if they were really sitting
next to each other at that exact time
and no one will ever know the Press will
never know that's routine law
enforcement and the doj prosecutors said
no we're not going to do that no reason
for that at all and Saul do you ever do
you also have a problem with the fact
that Leslie Wolf the assistant U.S
attorney was such close Pals with the
Biden political person who is working in
the same U.S attorney's Office this
Alexander mackler who had every he
probably had every position throughout
Biden's entire you know recent political
career all the way from Back to the
Senate
I have a problem with this case and and
This falls on former Attorney General
Barr and you know I'm a huge fan of his
uh but this never should have been sent
to Delaware and it was A.G Barr who
originally sent this tax investigation
into Delaware there was there was no
venue there it's a little tiny
incestuous district and office and given
the power of the bidens how and everyone
is connected to the bidens there it was
a huge mistake so I think the
relationship with her is just indicative
of that problem so really quickly the
plea deal with Hunter tomorrow do you
think the judge there's a chance the
judge would say no to that flea deal
given everything we've learned
there's a chance and I I certainly would
hope that she would hold off and and ask
for a little bit more uh more facts you
know that was people forget this this
was done in the Enron investigation
Andrew fastow's wife they cut a plea
deal for her and the judge down there
David hitner said no uh I'm not going to
I'm not going to accept this deal
because it controls what kind of
sentence I can give so look very
carefully it's outrageous to me that we
have still not seen the terms of the
plea deal the The Plea hearing is a day
away we need to know what those are
those will tell us a lot yeah insane but
predictable really Saul thank you great
to see you hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else